it's safe to say that hermione granger
and ron weasley have always been the end
game in the harry potter universe both
of these gryffindors are beloved fantasy
characters and they've always been
favorably shipped together however one
particular scene revolving around the
two characters relationship wasn't quite
as romantic in harry potter and the
chamber of secrets emma watson was quite
nervous to film a particular scene as
hermione and apparently angry with the
movie's director chris columbus for
making her do it anyway there's a
particular scene at the end of the film
in which hermione has to run into the
great hall and hug both harry and ron
however the shy then 11 year old watson
was too embarrassed to hug both of the
boys in front of the cast and crew
columbus tried to work around things by
making watson hug daniel radcliffe and
shake rupert grint's hand instead watson
was even embarrassed to hug radcliffe
for too long so their hug had to be
frozen for a few seconds longer than it
actually was for it to appear more
realistic on screen the actress has
since opened up on instagram about how
nerve-wracking it was to film that scene
with everybody on set watching watson
even said that her arms barely touched
around his
neck laugh this is actually quite
traumatic for me the result of the scene
actually ended up working perfectly for
the storyline of ron and hermione the
fans of the harry potter books and films
know of the underlying feelings that
both characters have for each other
hermione even ends up marrying the
endearing redhead at the conclusion of
the series if you're a true fan you're
up to speed on everything that happens
throughout their relationship adapting
books into movies can be extremely
challenging and many details are often
altered in the process despite some of
the major changes that had to be made to
fit within the restrictions of filming
the second harry potter movie harry
potter and the chamber of secrets still
holds up today watson grint and
radcliffe definitely grew closer over
the years as the movie franchise went on
however it seems like the actress's
attitude towards filming more intimate
scenes with her co-stars never changed
in harry potter and the deathly hallows
part 1 one of the horcruxes shows on a
vision of one of his biggest fears it
just so happens to be hermione and harry
kissing the vision is strange and
intense and watson and radcliffe had to
make it look really passionate speaking
with the seattle times watson said that
the experience filming the kiss with
radcliffe was quote bloody awkward
explaining dan and i are like brother
and sister but unlike her younger self
she put her all into the scene following
director david yates's directions with
the hope that it might help them finish
filming more quickly as the scene is
supposed to be a vision seen by ron
grint was originally on set to watch
them kiss and give accurate reactions
but apparently grin couldn't control his
emotions at seeing his two best friends
making out grint shared emma sent me out
because i kept laughing it just looked
really strange
this scene is definitely more hands-on
than the chamber of secrets hug and
watson held it all together to get the
filming done it wasn't even the only
kissing scene she had to do for the
franchise ron and hermione finally make
their romance official with a kiss in
harry potter and the deathly hallows
part two being as close to grint as she
is with radcliffe watson told movies
ireland believe me we both wanted it to
be over equally as much as the other
it's honestly like kissing my brother it
was weird despite how they felt in real
life the kiss is a very important moment
for ron and hermione's relationship on
screen thankfully the two actors
successfully overcame the awkwardness to
make it look realistic
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]